disclaimer dieses video ist keiner
investmentberatung sämtliche investments
getan ohne erwartungen von gewinn ein
potenzieller totalverlust wurde wirklich
in kauf genommen und überlegtes handeln
ist keineswegs cool und kann existenzen
zerstören ich persönlich würde also
immer auch nur das aufs spiel setzen was
ich bereit bin komplett zu verlieren an
einem für euch vorerst unbestimmten tage
in der vergangenheit habe ich meinem
kumpel sebastian geschrieben
gemeint war damit ein experiment in dem
ich einzig und alleine basierend auf
einen redebeitrag minen aktien im wert
von 10.000 euro gekauft habe das sind
unternehmen von denen ich teilweise zum
zeitpunkt des kaufs noch nicht mal
wussten was sie überhaupt machen nun
wirklich eine aktion mit dem potenzial
alles zu verlieren oder aber wie viele
andere menschen in den letzten tagen um
ein investment zu verhundertfacht also
von 10.000 auf eine million
das war zumindest das video das ich
eigentlich machen wollte wie vor sich
herausgestellt hat dass ich damit
unbeabsichtigt teil einer revolution
unseres gesamten finanzwesens wurde in
der einfache leute milliardenschwere
wall street akteure in die knie zwang
und sie um mehrere milliarden
erleichtert haben dieses video erzählt
von aufstand zusammenhalt puren wahnsinn
marktmanipulation einem potenziellen
systemwandel schnellem reichtum
schneller armut und letztendlich von der
reise die man je 10.000 euro hingelegt
haben die ich in wien aktien investiert
habe deren wert sich in nur sieben tagen
verzehnfacht hat dieses video wird
ausdrücklich nicht unterstützt von einem
der mehreren online broker die mir dafür
teils fünfstellige beträge angeboten
haben sondern von meiner eigenen app
deines gelb in der ihr einem die nur
einen zwinger umschnallen und mit einem
kumpel in der hand zusammen mit freunden
vor kometen wegbrechen könnte der link
zur neuen update 1.8 punkt null ist in
der video beschreibung
jeder der mal mit dem thema aktien in
berührung gekommen ist weiß dass es
neben den normalen privatanlegern auf
dem aktienmarkt noch die gibt die das
geschehen wirklich bestimmen häufig sind
damit hedgefonds an der wall street
gemeint die unter anderem durch
algorithmus gesteuertes handeln im
bereich von millisekunden den markt zu
ihrem gunsten beeinflussen
marktmanipulation das spekulieren mit
lebensmitteln fehlende regulationen gier
und letztendlich die wirtschaftskrise
von 2008 liessen die wall street zu
einem klaren feindbild heranwachsen
welches seinen bisherigen höhepunkt in
der occupy wall street -bewegung 2013
fand bei der tausende demonstranten die
wallstreet buchstäblich belagerten wie
konnte es also im januar 2021 ein
einzelner privatanleger namens kate gill
von seinem schreibtisch aus etwas ins
rollen bringen dass dieses ganze system
aushebeln und die finanzeliten mit ihren
eigenen waffen schlagen sollte wir
reisen zurück in das jahr 2012 in dem
jamie rosinski auf der plattform rettet
die gemeinschaft wall street begründet
in der sich gelinde gesagt risiko affine
privatanleger versammeln was als
lustiger interessens austausch mit
glücksspiel charakteristik beginnt
explodiert durch den immer leichter
werden den zugang zur börse gepaart mit
der kugel 19 pandemie und dem damit
einhergehenden steigenden interesse an
privaten handeln von aktien und co
allerspätestens mitte 2020 entsteht so
rein objektiv betrachtet eine zumindest
teilweise koordinierte einheit die von
den giganten der industrie aufgrund
ihres einflusses auf die märkte war
kritisch beobachtet wird auch wenn
zuerst wohl unterschätzt da dieses
phänomen der koordination in form von
humorvollen - auftritt und übersät ist
mit selbstironie zu sehen zum beispiel
am stolzen teilen und leiden von
millionen verlusten oder auch an der
fast selbstreflexiv wirken den eigen
bezeichnungen als und ich zitiere
autisten und degenerierte in diesem
pulverfass war also wer jetzt schon
legendäre keith haring kitty das
streichholz als er mitte des jahres 2020
die aktie gamestop untersuchte eine
firma die weltweit bekannt ist für den
physischen vertrieb von videospielen und
konsolen ein unternehmen welches als
leben der leiche guides im angesicht der
digitalisierung doch der ehemalige
finanzberater war anderer meinung
und nannte in seinem youtube videos
gründe warum gamestop ein comeback
hinlegen könnte seiner meinung nach wäre
die firma unterbewertet der online
wandel der spieleindustrie findet
deutlich langsamer statt als angenommen
und games management arbeite erfolgreich
an modernisierungen das alleine war aber
nur der startschuss die mehrheit glaubt
er wohl nie an die zukunft von gamestar
aber genau darin findet sich auch das
schlupfloch fast wie ein bug mit dem das
finanzwesen ausgehebelt werden konnte
denn auch die finanzstarken hedgefonds
glauben schon lange nicht an in zukunft
von gamestar wir glaubten sogar so sehr
nicht an die zukunft von gamestop dass
sie unverhältnismäßig unfassbar hohe
summen von geld auf den ruinen der firma
gewettet haben vor allem so genannten
short selling dabei profitiert man nicht
wie beim üblichen aktienkauf von
steigenden kursen sondern eben von
fallenden sehr grob vereinfachend sich
zum beispiel heute eine person eine
aktie und verkauft sie sofort für ihren
aktuellen wert von 100 euro
nach einer woche ist der kurs der aktie
wie erwartet auf 50 euro gefallen also
kaufte die person zu diesem preis wieder
eine aktie und gibt sie seinem leihgeber
zurück seine schuld von einer aktie ist
damit verglichen und die 50 euro
differenz
die gehören ihm sollte der aktienwert
aber nicht fallen sondern unerwartet
steigen muss die person seinem leihgeber
natürlich trotzdem irgendwann seine
aktien zurückgeben und diese dann für
zum beispiel 200 euro zurückkaufen und
macht somit 100 euro verlust der
zeitpunkt wann man so eine nummer
auflöst und beendet kann zum beispiel
kommen wenn man sich denkt hey 50 euro
profit nehme ich mit ich bin raus oder
mann waren was so lange die richtigen
twann irgendwelche idioten auf reddit
den kurs hoch treiben dass man sich bei
einem weiteren anstieg einmal
verschulden würde und dazu gezwungen ist
die aktion aufzulösen und das wirklich
witzige eine sache ist das wenn man das
macht also uns eine shortposition
auflöst da muss man wie eben erklärt die
aktie erst mal wieder kaufen um sie
zurückzugeben
man muss sie erstmal kaufen ja und das
trotz dem preis natürlich noch weiter
nach oben ja und wenn das problem hat
zum beispiel mehrere hedgefonds haben
will man natürlich nicht der letzte sein
der da am höchsten punkt rausgeht und
als resultat werden in extrem kurzer
zeit extrem viele aktien gekauft ja und
das ist dann der short-squeeze der trat
dann auch ein und löscht melvin capital
verlor in einem monat 53 prozent von
ihren ursprünglich 12,5 milliarden
insgesamt verloren us hedgefonds über 70
milliarden dollar unser tief geld wurde
hingegen mit einem relativ kleinen
investment in einem halben jahr zum
multimillionär und so auch zahlreiche
andere redet user und ich habe mein
experiment aktien von gleich mehreren
firmen in einer ähnlichen position wie
gamestop gekauft bei gamestop bin ich
hier eingestiegen und wie ihr seht war
das dann nach drei stunden auch schon 50
prozent im plus und das ist unfassbar
verrückt alleine diese bewegung waren 30
prozent in nur 15 minuten das thema rund
um gamestop dominierte das ganze
internet als caps kein ende in sicht
das hier ist die wachstumskurve vom
tablett wall street bett an diesem einen
tag werden gefühlt mehr beiträge geteilt
dass im ganzen jahr zuvor aber es geht
nicht nur um schnelle gewinne sondern
auch darum ein zeichen gegen die hedge
fonds zu setzen und junge erwachsene
buchen ganze wärme reklame um gamestop
und co in die höhe und die wall street
giganten damit in den miesen zu treiben
und ja das hier ist der times square
doch plötzlich beschränkt der
online-broker robin hood und andere
schlichtweg den freien handel angeblich
zum schutz der kunden vor sich selbst
wird es der handel für diese aktien
einen seite das heißt trotz der enormen
nachfrage können neue aktien nicht
gekauft alte aber verkauft werden was
nach den regeln von angebot und
nachfrage natürlich unweigerlich dafür
gesorgt hat dass ich das denn dass das
dass uns das entwickelt hat und so quasi
sofort und das hat den hype um das ganze
noch mehr bevor erst dann zum beispiel
der blogger robin hood arbeitet mit vom
short squeeze betroffenen hedge fonds
zusammen so verlangt der broker zum
beispiel keine gebühren sondern
finanziert sich durch das verkaufen von
nutzerdaten an hedgefonds die diese
auswerten und da wurde natürlich der
verdacht schnell groß dass die unter
einer decke stecken das ende vom lied
ist der wahnsinn ist mittlerweile
vorerst abgeflacht sowohl robinho jeff
blatt nf als auch kiel werden im
us-kongress einer anhörung unterzogen
und mein investment von 10.000 euro habe
ich noch nicht verkauft damit ist meine
position bei gamestop von 2.340 um über
80 prozent auf 42 eur gefallen da ich
aber natürlich flächendeckend
diversifiziert in verschiedenen im soc
investiert habe ist ein gesamtinvestment
von knapp 10.000 euro
nur um 47 prozent gefallen also 4300
euro verlust es war mir ein vergnügen
bei diesem abenteuer dabei gewesen sein
zu können
bis jetzt nur noch mal abschließend
setzt nie gegen das ausspielen von dem
wir nicht auch bereit wird es zu
verlieren wenn er jetzt einen deutlich
besseren investment sucht steckt doch
gerne mal meine eigene app deinen skills
die ist komplett kostenlos und ihr könnt
auch nichts verlieren kleiner spaß es
gibt natürlich die käufer so könnte er
richtig viel verlieren
natürlich nur wenn ihr wollt und es gibt
auch ein astronauten mit der
beschreibung tour im monat ich wollte es
nun gesagt haben könnt euch die app auf
android und ios und bald auch steam man
dann sehen wir jetzt gleichen
multiplayer und dann würde ich sagen
alles gut
[Musik]
also werden kurz gesagt